so recently the Home Secretary of the
United Kingdom government was on
breakfast news or something along those
lines and was talking about how
criminals are using end-to-end
encryption to essentially evade
detection and this is unacceptable now
in some sense that's very much true it
is unacceptable criminal activity is
unacceptable but what they're suggesting
is that we find a way to remove this
encryption or we find a way of only
allowing certain parties like trusted
government parties to have access to it
so before we declare that as insane
let's let's look at what that means and
what end-to-end encryption is and if
that's even feasible let's imagine that
I'm using whatsapp or Facebook messenger
or some other end to end encrypted
messenger with you right so you have a
phone here alright could be a phone
could be a computer it's not really
important some device right with a
screen this is why I'm not employed to
design these things this is you but I'm
gonna call you Alice this time because
we always do that does that make you Bob
it does so we've got Alice and Bob here
having a communication between two
phones there's going to be some
communication mechanism between these
two devices right it could be SMS or you
know GSM phone signal or it could be
something like Wi-Fi over the Internet
in all of these cases there's usually
going to be an intermediary server
handling this transport these phones
aren't capable of connecting to each
other on their own apart from things
like NFC where you come really close so
it's going to be some server in here
which I'm just going to label s which in
the case of whatsapp will be a whatsapp
server and obviously going to be a
server for whatever product you're using
now anytime that Bob sends Alice a
message is going to go via this server
by definition because that's the thing
that relays the messages to Alice it
knows how to communicate the Valis you
know it knows what her phone number is
it has lists of your contacts and things
you know this is how it works this could
be a phone provider and there's going to
be you know phone antennas and things in
this mix but it's not important so this
message here is going to come in this
way from Bob and it's going to go over
to Alice like this the issue is if we
want to encrypt this channel right we
want certain people not to be able to
read it if I'm sitting on a Loutre
somewhere on the internet here we don't
want me to go as I Smith
with your credit card details in half
that right so that's what we're trying
to avoid here yeah you can sit there
absolutely and people do encryption of
channels is nothing new right we've seen
it for a long long time right these
these techniques things like public key
cryptography and some of these ciphers
have been around for many years so how
do we do this well there's really two
options the first is that Alice could
negotiate some shared secret key with V
server
we'll call back key K a s so that key
there could be used by Alice to talk to
the server and she could send a message
encrypted by Kas to the server and say
please can you forward this message to
Bob Bob will have another key with the
server KBS and that's what he uses to
communicate obviously the here Alice
doesn't know what KBS is and Bob doesn't
know what Kas is the server decrypts a
message using Kas that it knows and then
re encrypts it with KBS and forwards it
to Bob
now this is not end-to-end encryption
because obviously it's been decrypted
halfway through in some sense that's a
good thing
my if I'm a terrorist or criminal and I
send a message
this server could perform some kind of
rudimentary checks to make sure I wasn't
doing anything untoward but for obvious
reasons a lot of people don't like this
idea what M twin encryption does is
replace these two keys with a key that
only Alice and Bob know the idea being
but this server is quite happy to relay
the packets back and forth but it
doesn't have any idea what's in them and
this works out very well for this server
as well because when someone says can
you give us this data they can
reasonably say no not because we don't
want to but because we actually can't
the process we use for this is something
called a key exchange the obvious
problem here is that at some point
Allison this server have got to share a
key without an encrypted Channel when
she first ever connects they haven't got
this key yet right and so how do we get
the key there's sort of chicken and egg
problem the solution was proposed by
Diffie and Hellman which is but if
ikemen key exchange
right we're not going to go into the
details of mathematics of difficult in
this video but I'll simply say that
Alice and Bob both have public and
private components of this key they
share the public ones and then they use
the private ones in secret to create a
shared key but no one else can know
that's essentially how it works so it's
a way of even via the server
producing a shared key Kay
a bee that no one else knows so now they
have this shared communication channel
so when you first connect you will send
some identifiers to the server you will
establish a public and private key pair
and then from then on anytime you want
to connect to anyone new you will
generate one of these keys it's called a
ephemeral which means that basically you
generate one almost every message if not
every message for some of these apps the
important thing is that the server or
vova relayed these messages is not
involved in this key exchange process
and can't inject itself in the middle
which means that it doesn't know what
kab is and it can't decrypt the message
physically where the Minister or someone
in the media says what we really want to
do is allow some kind of entry for
government into this system you can
quite reasonably say that isn't possible
because you'd have to inject something
in the middle of this key exchange which
will completely undo it so let's think
about the different ways we could do it
and discuss whether they're practical
okay so the first one is we could go
back to this system here so we can have
Alice talking to the server in a secure
way using a key exchange we can have Bob
talking to the server in a secure way to
a key exchange and the advantage would
be that if let's say a judge ordered a
warrant on some of this data the company
would have it on their servers probably
decrypted and they could send off in
some sense I don't absolutely object to
that because I don't really have
anything to hide well that's the obvious
argument but the problem is that if this
server ever gets hacked everyone's
messages and emails and pictures get
dumped out on the Internet right we've
seen that happen lots of times we can't
know for sure that this is secure right
so in some sense what we're doing is
introducing a very big point of failure
that could be catastrophic simply so
that the very few people that do things
illegally could we could serve a warrant
on those people another alternative but
forgets sort of suggested is this kind
of backdoor now in some sense this is a
backdoor already this double key
mechanism but when we talk about a
backdoor what we're really talking about
is some mathematical property of this
key exchange that no one else knows
about that means that we could actually
decrypt the messages is the idea again
this is a huge problem it's a problem
because if someone else a criminal finds
out this flaw
then again all our photos are dumped out
onto the internet and it seems unlikely
to me but the majority of people who
found this floor would publicize it
straight away right they would quite
happily
sit on it and see what interesting
things they could find out that's a kind
of that kind of worrying so again I have
some concerns about that approach as
long as we don't have a back door and
there's no way for them to get in there
oza
well so yes and no right the issue is
that the messages have to be decrypted
somewhere because they have to be
presented onto your screen right so
Alice receives this message her mobile
app receives the message using kab it
decrypts it and then it's on the screen
right at this point someone just steals
a phone runs off and reads a messages or
bugs the phone and read some messages
routinely hasn't forwarded on in this
day and age of quite secure end-to-end
encryption the much more likely target
of attack is not the encryption itself
it's just the endpoints so I've got your
phone here right which you've kindly
left the pin code off for me and I can
just scroll through your messages and
read them all right they're not
encrypted because that encryption has
been removed once it got to this end
point well yes to have a good user
experience it's got to essentially hide
all that encryption away and it presents
you with a nice set of unreadable
messages
so in some sense then your security
relies on your pin code and the
operating system running on your phone
or your laptop device and if those are
vulnerable then you know it really via
the end-to-end encryption is completely
circumvented
this is directly adding content to my
normal vision the problem is the area
that it has to add this content is
really very narrow I think it's the
equivalent of